bonjour avez vous déjà entendu parler de
cette troublante histoire celle des
esclaves oubliés de l'île tromelin perdu
au coeur de l'océan indien entre
madagascar et l'île de la réunion l'île
tromelin est aussi nommé l'île de sable
un lieu imprégné d'histoire et de
mystère pourquoi des esclaves
ont-ils été abandonnée sur un simple
banc de sable combien de temps son qu'il
restait sur sept il compile mis en place
pour survivre et surtout est-ce qu'il
reste encore des traces de leur passage
aujourd'hui de nombreux archéologues ont
mené l enquête et nous délivre un récit
bouleversant et pour vous raconter cette
histoire fascinante je serai accompagné
un dock seven qui parraine ce troisième
épisode
bienvenue dans cabinet curieuse
[Musique]
et
nous sommes en 1760 le navigateur
français jean de lafargue est missionnée
par la compagnie des indes orientales
pour ravitailler les colonies françaises
de l'océan indien
il prend le large à partir de bayonne à
bord d'un navire nommé dutil il joue un
deuxième navire nommé de l'agréable d'où
l'expression joindre l'utile à
l'agréable
c'est faux il n'a qu'un seul navire
celles utiles qui va arriver à
destination île maurice en avril 1761 la
même année il reprend la route direction
madagascar et c'est à ce moment précis
que les ennuis comme à bord de ce bateau
se trouve 142 marins mais aussi
cent soixante esclaves malgaches enfermé
dans la cale à savoir à l'époque la
traite négrière est interdite par le
gouverneur de l'île maurice pour ne pas
avoir à nourrir des bouches
supplémentaires alors qu'ils sont en
pleine famine le capitaine et ses
matelots cache donc les esclaves dans la
soute dans le but de les revendre en
douce sur l'île maurice et pour prendre
encore moins de risques le capitaine
fait un très gros détour vers le nord
pour éviter les contrôles manque de pot
pendant ce détour tard dans la soirée du
31 juillet 1761
le navire se fracasse sur le récif
corallien qui entoure une toute petite
île de 1 kilomètre carré l'île de
tromelin sur les 302 personnes à bord on
ne compte qu environ 200 survivants dont
80 esclaves le reste d'entre eux étant
enfermés à double tour dans les cales
c'est plus de 100 malheureux qui meurent
noyés dans la foulée les marins ne perd
pas de temps en quelques semaines
seulement ils construisent une
embarcation de fortune grâce aux restes
de l'épave
mais il ya quand même un gros problèmes
qui se posent à eux cette embarcation
nommé la providence n'est pas du tout
assez grande pour transporter tout le
monde
les 122 marin embarque abandonnant
lâchement les soixante esclaves qui ont
survécu jusque là en leur promettant
qu'ils reviendront les chercher avec de
l'aide
la question est donc sont ils vraiment
revenu les premières heures puis les
premiers jours passent et malgré le
soleil le manque d'eau et de nourriture
et la météo capricieuse il décide de
faire tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir
pour survivre ils usent d'ingéniosité et
de créativité pour conserver cet élan de
vie
dans ce milieu si hostile et vous allez
être surpris d'apprendre ce que ces 60
naufragés sont capables de faire sur une
si petite île c'est vraiment pas grand
chose comme ressource
maxime guerre ou archéologue très
renommé pour ses travaux de recherche en
archéologie sous-marine a piloté quatre
expédition archéologique sur l'île de
tromelin entre 2006 et 2013 pour étudier
ce naufrage est la survie de ces 80
rescapés les fouilles ont fait émerger
des choses plus que surprenante
lille étant entièrement vierge les
naufragés récupère et exploitent chacun
des objets en restant de l'épave ils
construisent de grande bassine en cuivre
pour récupérer l'eau de pluie
il fabrique aussi des bols des cuillères
ils creusent même des pluies jusqu'à
atteindre de l'eau saumâtre une eau dont
la teneur en sel est bien inférieure à
celle de la mer le feu étant un élément
tout aussi primordial il fabrique aussi
des briquets un précieux objets pour
rallumer le feu en cas de temps habiter
en effet c'est il subit régulièrement
des tempêtes tropicales voir des
cyclones max guérout y a également
découvert une lettre fascinante qui
décrit leur quotidien pour rester en vie
ils mangent des oiseaux et des tortues
de mer il se crée des pagnes à l'aide de
plumes d'oiseaux pour se couvrir et
construisent des habitations très
ingénieuse il faut savoir que sur cette
île le vent souffle en permanence et
pour se protéger des puissantes
bourrasques les naufragés construisent
d'épaisses murailles de corail les murs
ont jusqu'à un mètre 60 et leur
épaisseur est de quasiment 3 m ces
maisons de pierres et de corail sont
justement la découverte la plus
étonnante puisque la structure créée et
très innovante et très éloignées des
habitudes de construction de la société
malgache chaque construction est
organisée autour d'une cour centrale
dont les bâtisses à dos les unes aux
autres ce qui n'est pas le cas à
madagascar où les maisons sont
traditionnellement construite dans un
enclos individuel pour max guérout cela
témoigne d'une forte solidarité parmi
les naufragés
par ailleurs les esclaves dont
transgresser un interdit lourd de sens
dans leur culture en effet pour
construire leur habitation ils vont
utiliser des pierres or dans la culture
malgache les pierres sont exclusivement
réservés à la conception des tombeaux en
bref ils ont bâti une véritable micro
société avec ses propres codes sociaux
et sa nouvelle culture
c'est ce qu'affirme thomas romon
archéologues qui explique que ces
individus
on reconstruit une société ensemble et
on se rend compte qu'ils sont allés au
delà de la simple survie puisqu'ils ont
aussi fabriqué des objets au delà de
l'utilitaire et du fonctionnel mais
comment cette histoire c'était le
terminer arrivé à madagascar
dans la foulée le lieutenant du navire
lutte il prévient les autorités essayent
par tous les moyens de retourner sauver
les naufragés
malheureusement le gouverneur de l'île
maurice furieux que son interdiction de
traite n'ait pas été respectée refuse
catégoriquement le lieutenant envoya
même une lettre environ dix ans plus
tard au ministre de la marine lui-même
pour le supplier d'aller voir c'est un
petit peu long pour une saison de koh
lanta est pourtant une lueur d'espoir
pointe le bout de son nez lorsque les
naufragés voit arriver un navire envoyé
spécialement pour les secourir nommé la
sauterelle le bateau jette l'ancré est
en voie de marans sur un petit canot
pour aller le chercher des esclaves plan
qui tombe malheureusement à l'eau
puisque le canot se fracasse contre les
coraux l'un des marins rejoint la
sauterelle à la nage tandis que l'autre
ou sûrement moins bon majeur je sais pas
trop se retrouve coincé sur l'île entre
temps les récifs ont coupé le câble de
lancre de la sauterelle qui doit alors
rentré à l'île de france et des faits
l'ancien nom de la réunion en laissant
une personne de plus sur l'île de
tromelin
le matelot abandonné par ses compagnons
restent bloqués là pendant des mois et
arrive à construire un radeau de fortune
avec lequel il quitte l'île accompagné
de trois hommes et trois femmes
l'embarcation ne sera jamais retrouvée
après la tentative de rescousse de la
sauterelle il a fallu trouver une âme
suffisamment charitable pour aller
risquer son bateau là où d'autres ont
fait naufrage
tout ça pour sauver quelques esclaves au
bout de leur vie s'ils sont encore en
vie
c'est seulement quelques années plus
tard le 29 novembre 1776 qu'un nouveau
navire
la dauphine viendra clore la tragédie de
ces esclaves oubliés
la fin d'un calvaire qui aura duré 15
ans le nom de lille vient d'ailleurs du
capitaine de ce navire
jacques-marie de tromelin et quelle
surprise en découvrant les survivants
enfin je devrais dire les survivantes
en effet les gi personnes vivent là bas
sont sept femmes et un bébé de huit mois
au final ce seront une cinquantaine de
personnes qui auront perdu la vie là-bas
selon les archéologues les personnes
sont mortes de faim ou de soif peu après
le naufrage et pour les autres selon le
témoignage de cette femme
un groupe de dix-huit naufragé aurait
tenté de prendre la mer à bord d'un
radeau de fortune
n'a probablement jamais touché terre ce
que l'on sait du destin début rescapés
c'est qu'elles ont refait leur vie à
l'île maurice et qu'elles ont fermement
refusé de retourner vivre à madagascar
de peur de redevenir des esclaves
la psychanalyse daniela gariglio prend
aujourd'hui l'île de tromelin comme un
exemple de résilience et de volonté elle
explique que les survivants de tromelin
sur la démonstration scientifique du
fait que quand la pulsion de vie s'allie
à la pulsion créatrice qu on peut
survivre en se réinventant une vie max
guérout dit d'ailleurs que cette
tragédie est sans doute l'illustration
la plus extrême la plus révoltante de
l'horreur qu'ont été la traite négrière
et l'esclavagé mais l'ingéniosité la
farouche volonté de vivre des naufragés
sont aussi un triomphe sur la barbarie
de leur bourg
[Musique]
dites moi quels sujets vous rêveriez de
voir dans cabinet curieuse vous me dites
dans l'espace commentaires et j'irai
faire mon marché à l'intérieur
merci beaucoup à doc seven d'avoir
parrainé cette chaîne il ya quelques
années déjà et aujourd'hui ce troisième
épisode du cabinet curieuse je vous mets
un lien vers sa chaise dans la
description
je vous invite à le découvrir il ya
énormément de vidéos sur plein de sujets
très curieux
si vous ne connaissez pas également mon
magazine qui s'appelle curieuse qui
existe maintenant depuis quatorze ou
quinze numéros sa magazine papier
mensuelle de plus de 52 pages on est
passés bientôt la 62 pages je vous
invite à regarder le lien également qui
est dans la description c'est un
magazine qui assouvit la curiosité du
cerveau et sa soeur tous les mois 10
numéros par an directement dans vos
boîtes aux lettres pour 29 euros 90
quand à moi je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard ça ne change pas c'est très
pratique je vous invite à vous abonner à
cette chaîne a activé la cloche pour ne
pas rater les prochaines vidéos et à
liker cette vidéo si elle vous a plu ici
je vous mets deux autres vidéos
les deux premiers cabinets curieuse l'un
sur l'île de la rose et l'autre sur
l'affairé xavier dupont de ligonnès
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous